Michael Jackson's family is challenging
allegations of sexual abuse against the
late pop icon in a new HBO documentary
the movie that premieres this weekend
shares the stories of Wade Robson and
James safe Chuck who claim Jackson
abused them when they were young
children
Jackson has faced similar allegations in
the past he settled a 1993 case was
acquitted in a 2005 criminal trial
throughout it all Michael Jackson denied
any abuse but continued to surround
himself with young children even
inviting them into his bed we asked his
family about that behavior when they
spoke to us first on CBS this morning
about the documentary I heard in the
movie that there were actually things
that were called love letters Michael
Jackson's nephew Taj says he's a
survivor of sexual abuse by a relative
on his mother's side he shared notes of
encouragement that he got from his uncle
when he was a child
similar to ones safe Chuck and Robson
say they received my uncle gave letters
like that all the time the people that
he cared about mm-hm and there's nothing
salacious about it when you actually
know there's a lot of people even did it
to fans Taj Jackson says he spent much
of his childhood at his uncle's
Neverland Ranch and took part in many of
the famed slumber parties with children
there it has been well-documented your
brother spoke many times about sharing
his bed with young children did any of
you it was afraid of that well when you
phrase that you know sharing it's been
young young kids having they have sleep
of campout and just you know everybody
just stay in the bed and fall asleep
kids kids were there tiresome with a
little at the time and they all fall
asleep in the bed and watching movies
and so you can twist it saying sharing
his bed but yes but it makes you think
something else did it not seem on to you
though that your brother would share a
bed or have slumber parties with young
children yeah I think I do up in it so
for me it wasn't odd it was a lot I
think to the outside world yes I think
it can be odd I mean I'm not oblivious
to what it sounds like but when you're
actually there in that atmosphere and
you're around it and you're watching
movies those kids - yes with this
it's very innocent but I think the fault
of my uncle was he just he didn't have
that bone in his body to look at it the
other way his naivety was his downfall
that's what hurts me more than anything
is knowing his innocence but then
knowing how the world is in early 1994
Jackson settled a civil suit with a
family of jordan chandler a boy who had
accused the pop star of sexually abusing
him despite paying over 22 million
dollars in that settlement jackson
continued to surround himself with young
children there are interviews with
michael where he has said sure people
spent time in my bed it was loving it
was a fun time it was pure and anyone
who thinks anything other than that just
has a dirty mind that had said from the
outside world looking in it is very odd
you all don't think that it's odd that
he would spend time let me say something
when we grew up coming up traveling on
the road we was older but Marlon and
Michael was much younger they never had
a regular childhood life Michael always
had been a kid at heart always he loved
Disney Land he loved those so he tried
to create that world himself he loved
that world he loved making kids happy
his whole life was to to make the whole
world come together yes he said that's
what it's all about especially children
he loved that I mean I think just
knowing my uncle and spending thousands
and thousands of hours with them he
would always ask us questions like what
was this like what was it like going to
a birthday party you know because he
didn't have that he thought vicariously
through me and my brothers and you know
his nephews none of you at any time said
you know Michael this doesn't look good
I know your intentions are pure but this
doesn't look good none of you at any
time said that to him I didn't you did I
did I did I asked him I said maybe you
should just hang around family and he
said well that I'm not doing God's work
then I'm not helping people I'm not my
uncle always like to help people
that was my uncle's purpose that's what
he felt he was doing and he felt he
connected with kids because that was his
childhood as you sit here today are you
worried about what this documentary will
do to his legacy no no
but it does seem to be a day of
reckoning for many of you and we don't
want to get in the way of that but you
have to shine the light brightly on both
sides yeah I think you know you'll have
to watch the documentary and decide for
yourself I think The Jacksons clearly
support their brother and when people
say it's all about money they said they
don't get any money from the Jackson
estate they wanted to make that very
clear the people that get the money or
Michael Jackson's three children and you
know Wade and James when we here you
know he didn't have a childhood he was
very childlike I think when you hear the
documentary you may rethink what does
that really mean
raises a lot of very interesting
questions